[Musique]
l'allumage inversé c'est un allumage qui
va permettre d'allumer son poil très
rapidement d'aller voir d'avoir du
tirage tout de suite d'un conduit et de
pancrace et la vitre moi je vais d'abord
m sur la seule foi hier je vais déposer
les grosses bûches
vous voyez le bois il est en 33 cm il
est refondu
je vais déposer mon petit bois je mets
des allume-feu ces voix là c'est du bois
qui étaient compressés voyez c'est la
fibre de bois de la laine de bois qui
enroulait l'aï si elle est compressé
d'accord et donc ça ça va permettre
d'allumer le feu et de tenir une dizaine
de minutes pour qu'on ait une bonne
combustion mais c'est mieux parce que
votre vitre du coup elle sera pas va pas
sans crasse et à cause des résidus de
pétrole qui a dans les comptes utilisés
classiquement ou le papier journal qui a
de lancre qui va faire la même chose et
qui va bien sûr polluée voilà alors moi
je j'allume au chalumeau méga il allume
au chalumeau chez les clients aussi pour
la simple et bonne raison c'est qu'on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir d'allumettes avec
soin j'ai un chat du mot type avec un
petit zoo d'accord le chalumeau va me
permettre une chose qui est essentiel
avant le démarrage avant l'allumage de
l'appareil
c'est de mettre un petit coup de chauffe
dans le conduit et ainsi créer du tirage
voyez aujourd'hui il pleut donc j'ai de
l'air qui est très lourd dans le conduit
si j'allume mon poêle et ça risque de
refouler donc on peut en faisant cette
pratique
je vais créer du tirage tout de suite
dans mon poêle et on verra tout à
l'heure que ça ne fumera pas c'est à
dire concrètement avec le chalumeau vous
avez tout fait je vois là au même titre
que le montgolfier il va chauffer l'air
de sa montgolfière pour faire monter
donc moi je vais enlever l'air froid du
conduit pour créer du tirage
le réchauffe
d'ailleurs d'effecteur
et là je vais allumer
donc là j'ai allumé voilà vous allez
voir regarder ça déjà on a un peu de
tirage
mais comment le bois va prendre en douce
on va avoir une combustion descendante
donc combustion plus performant on va
reculer les gaz de fumées
en descendant c'est pour ça que vous
voyez là en fait on a allumé commune
bouge quand vous allumer une bougie
elle ne fume pas l'aca ne fume pas non
plus
[Musique]
tu m as folk